foreign
for over eight years in an abusive
marriage pretty much everything he just
never crossed the line enough for
authorities to get involved so let me
back out he crossed every single line
[Music]
what's up what's up what's up this is
John the Dr John deloney show show about
mental and emotional health
finding peace and joy in this chaos
trying to Wade through just the garbage
the onslaught of nonsense coming out of
Washington coming out of social media
coming out of your
friend's mom Deborah
I don't know sorry Deborah you may be
wonderful
but the advice you're giving might not
be here's the deal this is this show is
made up of real people going through
real challenges every day
just trying to figure out how to live a
better life
a better life a less anxious life so
grateful that you've joined us if you
want to be on the show give me a call
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask a-s-k and leave a message or write
in here's what's going on in my world
and Kelly or Jenna will give you a call
back and we will have you in on the show
um just a reminder I'm still still
beating the drum building a non-anxious
life is still in pre-sale it will be in
pre-sale for a few more weeks where I'm
gonna if you if you buy it for 20 bucks
now
um you can go to John deloney.com it's
20 bucks I'm gonna send you a bunch of
free stuff
um just for to say thank you for buying
it early
um inside the publishing company here it
is breaking all kinds of Records it's
just it's staggering the support you all
are providing for this book and I think
it's just hitting the nerve across the
country
um everybody wants to be less burned out
and less chronically stressed and
tackling
those as the issue themselves or
tackling anxiety as the issue itself has
not got us anywhere and this book is
about what's the layer underneath how do
I just build something different and I'm
so grateful to those of you who have
pre-ordered the book thousands and
thousands and thousands of you have
um but
let's do it go to John deloney.com and
pre-order it 20 bucks and one more
reminder on September 12th don't forget
there's going to be a live stream event
coming out of my the mothership where I
work Ramsey Solutions building with Dave
Ramsey Jade warshaw Rachel Cruz
talking about all right these loans are
due
gotta pay him back October 1st what do
we do
I build a whole life believing the
government when the government said hey
we're gonna take care of these for you
and they didn't what do we do now and so
it's gonna be a step-by-step plan here's
how to get out of this stuff if you're
anxious about your student loans please
check into this thing go to
ramseysolutions.com
student loans and get registered the
event is completely free 100 free no
asking you we're not like you need to do
that none of that none of that this is a
help this is this is millions of people
are asking what do we do what do we do
and our team said we got you we got you
all right let's run out to Nicole in
Kansas City Missouri what's up Nicole
hey um thank you so much for taking my
call of course I actually had a question
regarding like relationships so let's do
it um my question is how to not be a mom
in a relationship
um at the end of my last relationship I
was really like the mom and the maid and
it was very frustrating
um I kind of naturally like to just take
care of my partner and my current uh
boyfriend he doesn't need a mom like he
takes service off he takes care of me
but I'd just like to take care of him
and I want to know like if there's
something I should not be doing so that
later on in the relationship it doesn't
turn into that you know same Dynamic of
being the mom and the maid again
um or how should I act in a relationship
I guess I don't I didn't really see that
growing up so I don't really know how a
wife or girlfriend should act
well I mean I I
think asking a six foot two male that
question
um it's probably not I'm probably not
the person to answer it
um
I guess my my 30 000 foot questions for
you are
why do you conflate being a mother with
being extra caring and here's what I
mean by that some people are
um hard Chargers some people are
um I'm not gonna clean up anything
that's not who I am that's not what I do
I'm gonna I'm gonna film the blank I'm
an attorney I'm a go-getter I'm an
architect I'm a radio or whatever and
then some are like no no I was put on
this Earth to take care of the nest
right I just want to be at home I want
to take care of
my romantic partner I want to take care
of my kids I want to take care of the
dog I want to make sure the house is
perfect I like cooking like and so what
about what you feel
or what you're drawn to
isn't working for you
because you called because you don't
like it but I don't know why you don't
like it
I think it's probably because like
I don't know I really like my current
partner and I just I guess I'm nervous
that
it's gonna turn into the same thing as
last time where I don't know I guess I
feel like I'm a lot sometimes and like
you probably are I am
I think my wife's exact quote is you're
s you are a lot end quote
yeah I am what's wrong with being a lot
I don't know some people don't like it I
guess well some people can go on move on
down the road
yeah I guess I just want to get to the
bottom of like what you don't like about
Nicole
when you say you ended up being a mom
did you end up was it because you were
dating a child
yeah he was very selfish yeah you're
dating it you were dating a child that
was sitting before you in grown-up
muscles right and grown up skin yeah
yeah
so
yeah because like the gun was now he
definitely doesn't need it and he takes
care of me too
describe it break it break it down be
very specific what is it
like he doesn't he doesn't need me to do
everything for him but he appreciates
that I do it like like I don't know if
he's sick I make sure to have uh or he
gets migraine so I make sure to have
like Excedrin with me all the time so if
he gets a migraine he has he can take
the medicine or my gifts were like I'll
cook and like I'll set him down I'm like
do you need water you know but he also
does that stuff for me too I guess which
didn't happen in the previous
relationship so I guess I'm just
um
maybe you're uncomfortable because
you're in a
mutually affirming relationship for the
first time where you were going all in
on somebody and they're going all in on
you
yeah now I would tell a guy if you call
the show I'd tell a woman this too if
you suffer from migraines regularly
as a grown-up you should have Excedrin
on hand right and so it's different if
he starts to get a migraine and he looks
over at you in the car and he's like
where's where's the Excedrin and you're
like I don't know and he gets mad at you
throws a fit like a child a temper
Tantra oh my gosh you said you cared
about me you don't have Etc if you dated
somebody like that in the past think God
y'all aren't still together
okay because that's that's an immature
guy that hasn't grown up yet right he
doesn't want uh he doesn't want a wife
he doesn't want a girlfriend he wants a
maid
and you're you're worth more than that
now if you love thinking ahead and
caring for people
good for you man we need more people
like you out in the world
it's this it's when you get your
self-worth
from taking other things off other
people's plates to the point that they
can't live their lives because if they
live their life you feel less than
that's when it's a problem
so yeah no that's not how I feel if he
pulled Excedrin out of I don't know of
the console in the car and you instantly
felt shameful that should have been me
yeah you probably need to deal with that
you need to work through that yeah but
if the goal here is I just want my the
guy that I'm kind of falling for I want
him to not have a headache whether he
has it or you has that's awesome yeah
and I think ultimately you gotta make a
list you got to make a plan of
here's what I will and I do want to do
and don't want to do and then you need
to be okay with it if somebody looks at
that list and goes I'm kind of out
yeah it's heartbreaking it's hard
and when you mention your ex
you almost got choked up
what's that still hanging on you
I don't know what's
God it's so annoying
um
it just sucks because
like I did everything for him and he
cheated on me and then he said no I do
love you and I still want to be with you
and then he kept doing it so it's just
like
I don't know I guess it's like hard to
dress like yeah that I'm not being lied
to and that it is okay for me to be how
I am
have you sat down with your new
partner and said hey
um I haven't cheated on before so I'm a
little extra on edge sometimes
because if if I was dating somebody and
they told me that I would look him dead
in the eye and say and run I'll never
cheat on you number two anytime you feel
hey uh you ask and I'll tell you
yeah right yeah
yeah any like he's been very honest and
hasn't done anything for me to just
trust him and I even asked him if he
thought I was acting like a mom because
I am a lot and he's like no there's a
difference between caring and being a
mom like having to be a mom in a
relationship so
yeah I think um I think this is less
than being a mom and less this is more
about
you try to do everything you thought
there was a if I do this and if I do
this and if I do this and if I do this
then he'll love me
yeah and I need you to hear me say
that's not how love works
yeah
the problem in that I thought I was over
it but no because it's not about that
dude this is about you
yeah for some reason you think way down
in your core you have to do X Y and Z or
you're just simply not worthy of being
loved and that's just not true
caring for caring's sake is awesome
caring so the people around you have a
better day that's amazing the world
needs more of that
caring because oh my gosh if I don't do
this and this and this and this and this
I won't be worthy of love that's
exhausting
yeah and I like to just do it do it
because I like to do it and then when it
gets to the point where I have to do it
because they don't do it that's when I
get frustrated that's it that's then you
become a mom
yeah right so if I get home from the
road
and I've got a I get home from the road
late like last night I got in a little
bit late got home and I've got a small
little duffel bag and I dropped on the
floor and I gotta be back at work doing
media first thing today
my wife grabs that bag and she's like I
got this I'll throw this in with your
son's clothes
and the gasoline that she uses to wash
our clothes with
um that's awesome
if every day I'm just walking home and
dropping my clothes in a pile the middle
floor expecting her to clean up after me
then she becomes my mom so she stops
becoming a partner who's helping the
whole household helping helping me
to ugh I have to that's a toy and
everything and you know the difference
between those two
yeah I was nervous that I guess I
was because one of my previous
therapists says that we train people how
to teach us so I was nervous that my
over caring would train someone to just
I guess act like my previous
relationship which is just basically
like he said he'll just throw his stuff
down and expect me to clean it for him
yeah and that's it's twofold I mean
that's that's a very simplistic thing to
say there's some truth to it
but
so I I've talked to couples before and
let's say I'm just gonna just I'm just
gonna throw all the generalizations into
a big pot so if you're listening to this
everybody I know I'm over generalizing
everybody relax
um
but let's say she
it's a guy and a girl who are married
she does the laundry for the first one
year two year three years
then a baby comes along and she's
keeping up and she starts doing laundry
for year number four and then she just
hits a wall
gotta go back to work we have this kid
and then husband walks in one day and
there's no laundry and he's like what in
the world that's usually the point where
everyone goes gosh that dude sucks he's
the worst I can't believe right
and there's some truth to that he should
be helping out and
the person who's been doing the laundry
for three years
should say hey I am running hey this is
I need some help here because often
people don't know
it's not a pass it's not like oh are you
kidding me no I'm not kidding you people
don't know they don't know in seventh
grade my mom or sixth grade my mom took
me down to the laundry room put the
laundry soap on the washer and say this
is the last day I do laundry this is how
this machine works May the force be with
you right I had a mom that taught me a
lot of folks don't
a lot of folks don't or a lot of dudes
just don't do laundry right ever ever
ever right so there's something to be
said for speaking your needs out loud
saying them out loud and then if he
chooses to reveal himself as a jerk I'm
not doing that I no Mana Mod's gonna do
laundry in this house all right well
this is where we part ways
yeah right that's not that's not
I don't see that at all here so you do
train if you will your partner to just
expect expect and if things are going to
change I think it's fair to say it out
loud what you trained your boyfriend to
do last time
is that he could do whatever he wanted
including other people and you are still
going to be a doormat for him when he
got home
that was what you trained him on
until you said no no no I have more
self-respect I'm worth more than this
I deserve more dignity than this
Bye Felicia I'm out
yeah see what I'm saying so I don't
think you trained him to like always
I don't know washes little sippy cup
when he got done with it but I do think
overall he came to know she she's not
gonna do nothing
she ain't gonna do anything
and I think letting your new partner
know no I'm I'm serious about the
business of treating myself with dignity
and respect and being around people who
also treat me with respect and I love I
was put on Earth
to serve I love it it brings me joy
making your day better that's amazing
and somebody who loves you back won't
take advantage of that
yeah is that fair yeah definitely okay
well you speak them out and I think that
may be challenge number one because
you're afraid if you speak your needs
out loud that somebody's Just Gonna
Leave You
yeah and you need to not be fearful of
that
okay the second thing is I need you to
write this old boyfriend a letter that
you will never send him don't send it
okay somebody recently I told to write a
letter actually actually read it aloud
and I was like oh you shouldn't have
done that but
um I want you to write him a letter that
you're not going to send him
I don't want you to write it from
your heart this time
and I want the letter to be of such that
you are recognizing
I was a good person to date
I really cared about you and and I put a
lot into this relationship that as the
great comedian Michael J says is not
transferable I gotta start all over with
somebody else
but I worked really hard
and I forgave you I welcomed you back
and I forgave you again and I welcomed
you back
and you you hurt me
and I'm not carrying your bricks anymore
as though I'm I'm somehow damaged I'm
somehow broken that's you can carry
those bricks if you choose I'm not I'm
done Carrie
I'm out
and I want you to write that letter seal
it up
put it somewhere whether it's in a
shredder and put it set it on fire in a
fire pit whatever you want to do with it
I want you to be free of this guy I want
you to be free of how he treated you
and then be fully
ready to run into the next situation
with open arms saying I'm Nicole here's
what I need here's what I love are you
in
give somebody a chance to fully love you
back
most of us hedge most of us hedge most
of us hedge give him a shot
to Michelle we'll be right back
[Music]
hey good folks deloni here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time those become healthy habits
they almost become automatic like
choosing to slow down and make time for
a daily practice of prayer and
meditation one thing that has helped me
with my daily practice is hallow hallow
is the number one Prayer app in the
world and they're giving you three free
months to get started that's three
months for free to prioritize your
mental and spiritual health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music through guided prayers
meditation and more and by the way
Hollow isn't just Catholic you can
tailor the content towards your faith
tradition or if you don't have a faith
tradition it's a great place to start
from scripture readings to prayers to
journaling hallow makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember hallow is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hallow.com deloni today to start your
free trial just follow the simple
prompts at hallow.com deloney for 90
days free
all right let's go to Portland Oregon
and talk to Rich hey Rich what's up man
hey how you doing rocking and rolling
man what about you
I'm not doing okay
um what's up recent call today is uh I
my wife and I have been married for a
little over a year now uh we have a
three and a man uh three and a half
three and a half month old son
and uh recently she's uh well she's
bipolar too and she started going
through a hypomanic episode
uh which coming into the marriage I
really had very little idea of what sort
of things kind of surrounded bipolar too
um but as a result of it she uh
decided to kind of start her own
business and then spent
uh opened up some credit cards uh
without my knowledge and then uh spent
about seven to eight thousand dollars uh
and then was running around
missing most of the day uh while I was
home unfortunately I work from home but
I was home alone taking care of our
three and a half month old son
um all right
I'm kind of at a point where uh it's she
she's gotten a little bit better it's
kind of de-escalated in the last couple
of weeks
um but some of the financial stuff is
still out there and so I'm just kind of
trying to figure out what what I should
be doing and how to be better prepared
for when this happens again the next
time
um oh man
there's a lot here um really quick for
the for the audience
um
bipolar 2 is
a a relatively become relatively common
diagnostic diagnosis
um and it's different than bipolar one
from something they call hypomania which
means the UPS
the manic phase the phase where people
stay up for three or four days and that
goes on for weeks and then they collapse
and they're back up at it and they spin
recklessly or they will just go have a
ton of romantic part it looks different
for everybody but it's just a z
um
hypomanic means it's not quite as high
it's not quite Hispanic the other part
that usually accompanies bipolar 2 is
the depression phase
is often deeper it's a darker hole right
so
um
what your describe
rich I have a lot of thoughts and
opinions some of what you're gonna get
me in trouble is it okay if I just
kind of lamb all out in a row
sure go ahead okay
I like to
this isn't always a hundred percent
accurate but it helps me okay so
feel free to not use this if it doesn't
help you
I don't like to say
anxiety caused this
or depression caused this or bipolar
made this because that infers that we
live completely robotic lives
and I know
several some of them very closely bp1
and bipolar one and bipolar two folks
who have created worlds for themselves
where they take their meds
where they
um they do a lot of work upstream and
when they do enter into a really dark
phase or a high phase they got a plan
so what I don't want you to do is to
just look at like oh gosh this is the
next seven years of my life this is just
going to happen at some random moment
you're going to get a call like hey your
wife bought seven cars and she started a
car business that's not necessarily
deterministic that way right so I would
love you to say well my wife has been
diagnosed at some point with bipolar too
and all right she recently did X Y or Z
okay so you see what I'm saying and so I
don't I want that's going to impact My
Hope Is It empowers You and gives you
some all right all right let's do this
that's different than oh this is gonna
be what this is okay so that's number
one number two
um how long did y'all date before you
got married
uh for about two years and there was
never an episode never any sort of
anything like this you never experienced
any of it
uh no I had not the the closest we had I
was earlier this year her brother uh
also has bipolar and he went through a
similar episode
um so we at least had a little bit of it
but I even then I didn't really kind of
know what was going on I was basically
kind of third party just hearing about
everything okay but I know she had
several years ago uh gone through
another episode I've heard from her
family what kind of uh precipitated from
that but
uh was it also a reckless spending and
borrowing episode as well
uh spending and actions yeah there was
like she got a tattoo as a result of it
and uh decided kind of out of nowhere
just to get like a haircut which was you
know on on Surface nothing bad uh it's
very impulsive
yeah exactly all right so
um I'm gonna give you a recommendation
that I I fight against all of the time
and in 99.99 of the time I think is the
wrong move but I think it's the right
move for you right now
okay
what your wife needs what you need what
your household needs right now is you to
be able to find footing and to drop your
shoulders so that y'all can do what you
got to do coming forward
and you will not be able to do that I
don't believe until you know y'all are
safe
and so I think the smart thing to do
right now is to move your money into an
account where you can make sure the four
walls are covered your housing is taking
care of your utilities are taken care of
you can get gas money you get food okay
yeah fortunately I've already done that
kind of early on yet okay I think um
couples who split their finances I think
that's a terrible idea except in this
situation okay
um Step number two is she still burning
through cars or is she starting is the
light starting to come back on like oh
no because usually that's accompanied by
some pretty intense shame that then
kicks in the the black hole phase
uh no she has the stuff that can be
returned but wasn't like good since
there was services that we can't return
but the goods uh some of it has gotten
returned some of it we've found out we
really can't return
uh but we are kind of in the process of
getting all that and then
um we're hoping kind of by the end of
the month so
be somewhat close to the the
other kind of shoe to drop on it was
that we have
before all this we had been saving for a
house and so we do have about forty
thousand dollars saved up in
savings for the house that we were going
to basically just turn around and use
that to pay on the card so that they
didn't gather any sort of interest at
all sure but can you get I mean she ran
up what eight or nine thousand so could
she just pay them off
um that was that basically that's going
to be the plan at this point is to just
pay them off with worth it I would not
do that
unless she agrees to freeze her credit
okay so that if there's another
impulsive moment that it's very
challenging to go forward
okay
and here's what we have to do moving
forward we have to create with her you
can't do this for her because you're not
her dad you're her husband she has to be
willing to create put hurdles in her
path
so that
um if she
gets
um ends up acting very impulsively or
ends up and hurdles also
um for people who are
struggling with major depressive
disorder right or they are in a
depressive episode
maybe not how many guns in the house
maybe don't um there is a number
everywhere for somebody to call
we have a check-in program that we've
practiced right that there's there is
I'm gonna put some things in place so
that
I want to tell you I don't have bipolar
one or bipolar two nothing of the sword
and I also am pretty impulsive so
there's been seasons in my life when I
gave my debit card to my wife I didn't
have access to my own checking account
because I needed some time to cool off
and that was just me being a responsible
adult
okay
there is most of the time I do not have
junk food candy in my house because I
eat all of it and I know that um I
should be disciplined and I know that I
should all those I know all that
it's often easier for me just than I
have in the house
and I've made peace with that that's
okay
and so it's about her deciding I want to
be an adult and never put myself my
family in this position again
and
I've got some different challenges than
other people so I'm gonna put some
hurdles in front of me
would she be willing to do that or is
she not even a place to have that
conversation yet
probably not yet
um I mean right now she doesn't even see
the stuff as debt or her philosophy is
that it's not actually dead until uh
interest starts occurring on it uh so
we're
we're still kind of sliding the whole
actually just using credit cards uh to
begin with but
so it might be in concerned she still
she has started to kind of calm down but
uh
kind of seeing just how still
active she is with the idea of wanting
to start her own business and whatnot
um if you think she can if I mean I
don't know that you have the
deterministic like that but if you all
decide starting a business is right for
your young family for her great let's
just do it the right way
yeah and we and we have tried to
tell her that between myself and her
parents
um and there's
been pushed back but for the most part
our message has always been exactly that
it's just start off slow and scale yeah
absolutely um but she wants to go and
buy like she wants to start a cafe is
her idea so
um so I always recommend when somebody
wants to start a restaurant or a coffee
shop or open a bar go spend two years
working in a cafe
day in and day out
um sometimes where we love to go spend
time together it's a totally different
experience creating creating that
experience for somebody else to enjoy
their time because you're working right
but all it could say is
um that those conversations may fall in
deaf ears
um but I think they're at least worth
sitting on and having I think ultimately
you're gonna have to decide
um or she's gonna have to decide do I
want to be well or not well
and there is
um pharmaceutical interventions
especially in combination with
um therapeutic interventions right is
she seeing somebody
uh no not specifically right now with in
the midst of all this we did go to the
ER and they did adjust your meds
um so be we do have her on something
that's supposed to be helping her with
the hypomania specifically I think
you'll need to go spend some time with a
marriage counselor
okay and not just a run-of-the-mill one
but I would find a psychologist or
somebody who's trained working with
couples but also with
um uh uh mental health disorders
okay
and or somebody who's struggling with a
very particular thing and there are um
therapists that are excellent with
couples in bipolar excellent with
couples and borderline personality
disorder which is very challenging
um couples in OCD so there's there's
therapists that are really excellent at
at
helping couples draw boundaries helping
couples draw up plans so that we can
move forward What I Hear in your voice
and you just may be a super chill like
make your own granola Portland kind of
guy
but I hear in your voice you almost have
already given up
are you just tired
I think it's more the letter I'm just
exhausted okay uh trying to fight and
what not for what feels like a month now
I actually probably has been over a
month now it's just what are you
fighting
because let me tell you this in in a
manic phase there's no learning
so there's like having a re a
conversation about hey you know you
should probably go to bed
it's almost a a
conversation not worth having
or hey debt is actually this that's not
that that's this isn't that moment for
that conversation
it's more hey honey
when we as a couple owe somebody money I
can't breathe
when we as a couple have to pay for a
restaurant that we haven't even opened
yet
we haven't done the math on how many
cups of coffee we actually have to sell
just to pay the light bill nothing much
less the overhead much less the cafe
staff
I I
don't sleep I don't I don't breathe I
don't digest my food
um I think that's where we start
and that's different than starting with
math starting with hey this is actually
the definition of debt hey you shouldn't
scale this so much it is do you love me
enough to not hurt me because right now
your actions hurt they're scaring me to
death
and if you love me that if you love me
just that much just that much that's a
good place where we can start
right
that's the only way I've seen things be
effective I've rarely rarely ever seen
somebody win with a math problem or a
definition problem or something like
that but I think you guys got to get a
marriage counselor that's going to help
you as she comes down and um
I I think once the manic phase is over I
think getting meds readjusted again is
probably pretty important
um especially if she just got meds to
deal with the Mountaintop
um
yeah I'll leave it at that I think you
have to look at the entire picture of
your marriage I don't want you to cast
this thing off as this is going to be
the rest of your life or it has to be
the rest of your life it might be but it
doesn't have to be
um
she can make some choices
and you all can make some choices
together where this is not deterministic
um go ahead Kelly I have a question yes
so we had a call earlier
um in the week about bipolar one okay
and now bipolar two that's why I asked
you to explain it a little but I know
for most of us it's just
terms we don't get so I just want to I'm
wanting to know so it sounds like in one
the highs are higher and the lows are
lower is that is that it am I hearing
that correctly
yes I my understanding is the bipolar
one is is the intensity is is much
greater
and in bipolar two the highs aren't
quite as high
um but often as accompanied by a lower
low
um and so it that's
often the diagnostic is pretty
subjective right and um with all due
respect a lot of times bipolar two is
just something they throw
like I feel all over the place and I
feel really excited sometimes I feel
really low sometimes I can just put
bipolar 2 on there and call it and so it
is one of it's I think it's one of the
most overdiagnosed
um Diagnostics and I've met some folks
where it's very real right where it's
very very real
um I
that's that's why you just gotta be
honest about it if this is what you got
it's what you got
um similar like I struggle with X Y and
Z I still gotta be at work on time so I
have to create a world where I can be on
work on time so it's kind of the same
thing just different degrees of of the
symptoms to a point
for non-nerds yes okay and yeah yeah so
hyper means
a lot right and hypo means like the the
Mountaintop is curved it's more of a
hill than a mountain okay right it is
rarer than a hype hypomanic phase for
somebody to go on a spinning burnout
like this that's what makes me wonder if
there's more to it than that
um
or if this is just like a very
determined very very like we're going
forward
um or if there's a long family history
here that's why like it
when someone's listening saying why
don't you ask yes this I think most of
these questions for Rich and his wife
are gonna be for a counselor because
there's gonna be some Nuance here that's
that's gonna be when he said that the um
manic had been over a month at this
point how I mean I guess I never thought
that they lasted that long because I've
not never been around anybody yeah that
makes me very
that's that's that that in my estimation
is a long long long time okay because
that does seem exhausting it's a long
time
um for uh bipolar two hypomanic phase uh
but again I'm not an expert on it
um there may be moments when they last
that long that seems like a very very
long time from my experience
um but again there's experts out there
if you are uh bipolar two bipolar one
expert I mean you've got some opinions
on that please write in and I'd love to
read out like hey here's if you're a
clinician and you're a psychologist
um and you are navigating this and your
your specialty is bipolar one and two I
mean I would love
um if you want to provide some clarity
um we'll read it if you write in I'll be
happy to read that out it is for folks
listening
um but that's a great question but again
here's here's the bigger picture for
99.9 of us
those level of details
I think are only important if you use
them as limiting factors
and what I mean by that is
um
I'll just use this in my house
if I took I'm used my son who's in has
no mental health disorders whatsoever
he's an amazing young man I'm just using
him for an example if he was really
struggling and I took him to a child
psychologist who then did a work up on
him and said hey your child has bipolar
one
and then I took him to get a second
opinion and that person said his bipolar
too
I wouldn't care
what they have what I would want to know
is what is it about my son that he's
going to struggle with on a day-to-day
basis and what can we do so I don't care
if it's bipolar one and my UPS are like
this well this guy gave me bipolar too
but this has been a month now that
doesn't matter to me as much as
I felt so out of control for 30 days for
60 days I couldn't hear people who loved
me I spent recklessly I went bananas
let's start there the diagnostic fine
but let's start there and let's have
that conversation with the psychiatrist
let's have that conversation with a
psychologist and then again there's not
like one pill they can just like oh you
have an infection let's give you
penicillin that's not how that works
they're going to say okay let's try this
see if this works that didn't work let's
try this one let's try this one and it's
gonna be a slow management until that's
why they call it Med management until we
figure out
what for you works and that's why again
I just don't put a lot I don't care
about Diagnostics hardly ever
um it does if someone says I've been
diagnosed with borderline personality
disorder that's that's a light bulb for
me somebody says I've been diagnosed
with bipolar one that's a light bulb for
me or schizophrenia most of the rest of
them is okay tell me what's going on in
your life
um and that's just again I don't want to
sound nonchalant but most people are way
more complex in their diagnosis in most
situations are way more complex so
um but that's what rich is dealing with
right that's what this rich is dealing
with with the wife he loves and I'm
confident she loves him
and also just come with Rogue and went
out and bought a bunch of stuff started
a business got Mom and Dad saying hey we
love you and husband saying hey we love
you this isn't safe this isn't smart
this isn't safe I'm just plowing head
plan head plan ahead we have to deal
with that
um sometimes extra information is hey
here's the diagnosis okay cool that's
that's excellent we take that into
account but let's deal with hey we're
not safe because we've got a partner
who's just spinning recklessly that's
where I like people start but does that
help
yeah that's great okay hopefully uh I
didn't put everybody to sleep just then
no I don't think so okay all right hey
Rich we love you man um call back
anytime if you need something if your
wife wants to call in and I can help her
create a road map
um we'll only have a few minutes but I'm
happy to give it a shot
um if she wants to call in as well thank
you so much we'll be right back
this episode is sponsored by betterhelp
hey this is deloni I hope you all are
doing well listen sometimes it's hard to
get our brains to turn off and I know
what I'm talking about I am the king of
racing thoughts they've kept me up at
night they've got me up early and kept
me from connecting with people I love if
you find your thoughts start to race
right before bed or during other super
inconvenient times a great way to make
those racing thoughts slow down or stop
is to talk them through and therapy gave
me a place to do that so I could get off
the negative thought treadmill learn
positive coping skills set healthy
boundaries and find some mental and
emotional peace and it can help you too
if you're thinking of starting therapy
give better help a try better help is
convenient because it's entirely online
so it's flexible and can fit into your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and you can even
switch therapists at any time for no
extra charge so take a break from racing
Thoughts with better help visit
betterhelp.com baloney today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we're back let's go out to
Phoenix and talk to Emily hey Emily
what's up
hey hey John
um so my question is about
how do I allow myself or how do I have a
healthier relationship after living a
life for over eight years in an abusive
marriage
um I view the world through that lens
and I just don't know how to
have a relationship at this point yeah
no kidding
um what kind of abuse tell me about it
what you feel safe tell me about
um there's a lot of stuff I probably
can't say on the show but um it was
everything you can you can say whatever
you want to say say whatever you want to
say
um Financial abuse emotional abuse
sexual abuse that was
pretty much everything he just never
crossed the line enough for you know
authorities to get involved so let me
back out he crossed every single line
I don't want you to ever think that
well he didn't do it that bad he did
yeah right and you know that you know
that
um
the courts don't see that but I yeah I
know yeah I know it's heartbreaking
sometimes
um it's heartbreaking a lot of times
um
so my guess is you've tried to date
since then and it has not gone well tell
me about that
I am in a relationship and have been for
just over a year okay
um
he's a great guy but everything that he
does is I'd call a red flag even if it's
not you know I I just view everything
through the lens of trauma and feel like
you know it's always going to come bite
me
you know some like I'm missing something
you know has he bit you yet this new guy
as he what has he bit you yet not really
but you know what I mean no no no there
there's there's been nothing there's
just things that I say to myself well
maybe that's something and I'm missing
it okay
so trauma works by taking you away from
yourself right disassociating you from
yourself
and
your body's job is to make sure that
never happens again ever
right your body's just doing what it's
supposed to do
so your body's put
um try to say this as easy as I can your
body put a GPS pin
and love your body put a GPS pin in men
and said this situation this this bear
nearly killed us last time I'm gonna get
your attention every single time we're
around a bear
and so the goal of trauma healing is to
reconnect you with yourself
and to teach your body that you weren't
unsafe you I mean you weren't safe then
but you're safe now
and the scary part about that is in
relationship it's always vulnerable so
you're always going to be mostly safe
all right that's the worst part of it
um even last night I'm talking to my
wife and I said some very vulnerable
things and she could have said you're
such a baby oh my gosh I thought I
married a Texan I didn't realize that
she could have done that
and I would have had to deal with the
hurt of that she didn't
all right so it was vulnerable last
night I was nervous to say what I was
going to say so it's always going to be
a part of any sort of romantic relation
to any relationship father daughter
um father son parent anything work
relationship and especially romantic
there's always going to be that
vulnerability what you have to decide is
when that red flag comes up
and your body's get your attention and
says hey
I think we're missing something here
are you going to challenge that thought
are you going to run with it
how do you challenge it though because I
seem to just run with it
have you ever taken the time to write
some of these red flags down on a piece
of paper and actually stare at them and
say is this true
um not really it's a painful long
exercise and worth every second
because what you're going to do is he's
going to get home and he's going to be
texting somebody on his phone and he's
going to drop his phone face down
and your body's gonna go see told you
he's cheating I knew it
right there that's the moment you can't
help that lightning bolt that lightning
bolt is your brain's job or he comes in
and you feel he's angry and you want to
hide in the cabinets
that feeling that lightning bolt get out
now Emily go go go
that lightning bolt is real and true and
you can't really stop that initially
over time your body learns but in the
moment you can't what you do is have a
choice in that moment
to say is this true
and when he turns his phone over just
drops it because he's a goofball and he
has to go to the bathroom and he had a
long commute home
and you go is he cheating on me no
he's not
right and that's one of those moments
sometimes I used to put my hand on my
chest like is my wife really hate me
and I would be like no she doesn't
do I wish that she had just come in and
be like oh my gosh I'm so happy to see
you and give me a big hug do I wish that
yes
does she hate me though no
that I would literally practice dropping
my shoulders
and what I would not do is I would not I
would fight it and I would fight it and
I would fight it I will not have these
imaginary conversations
I'm not gonna let the person who used to
hurt me
continue to speak into my present
relationships where somebody's trying to
love me
and that's just something you gotta
practice
I'll also say there may be some trauma
counseling that you need to go deal with
and train trauma counselors those
trained in the works of Peter Levine and
Vander call could some of them use
Bodywork EMDR it's amazing what'd they
do
it's incredible what they do
and so it's you saying let me take some
time and go be well and really in a we
in a strange way I don't understand how
it works I'm sure there's some
neuroscientists that can figure it out
for me or some polyvagal scientists that
can figure it out for me your nervous
system
just control deletes it it it it just
goes it's like a it's a piece that I
can't describe other than I've I've been
through it and it feels like almost
almost like a depressive State because
my body's been running so hot for so
long
when you start to feel comfortable and
at peace and a little bit safe
is that when the symbols start crashing
the loudest
yeah
it is
yeah I think that's your body's last
Stitch effort
to keep you out of something that almost
got you last time
give me one example of something you'd
like to be different
one story that keeps spinning up that
you would like to to work on
as far as my current relationship yeah
um I feel like he's secretive okay on a
lot of things and I lived that with my
ex-husband and he was secretive for a
reason he was
uh doing a lot that he shouldn't have
been doing
so
if I'm you
I would feel absolutely comfortable
sitting down and I'm saying that
jokingly there's no way I'd feel
comfortable doing what I'm going to tell
you to do but um I would feel
comfortable sitting down saying hey I
was married before that guy hurt me real
bad
and I really like you
and also my body runs pretty hot the the
the antenna is pretty hot
and so I'm gonna have to practice and
learn to trust you
and it feels to me like you're being
super secretive what is if you tell me
about that and he might say can you give
me some examples of how I'm being
secretive so I'll ask you that what are
some examples of how he's being
secretive
um
things like that have you sat down and
said I'm uncomfortable with the fact
that I don't know the passcode to your
phone
I have not why not
um because again I view it through my
previous relationship and I know how
that went with him so I'm just it's
like I don't want to fight about it
I know what if it's nothing if it's
nothing then who cares
you know what I mean if it's nothing who
cares
who cares at all
yeah I guess I'm afraid I'm going to
push him away because of my insecurity
and my trust issues and
what happened to you in the past
happened to you in the past and anybody
who loves you is going to know
this person is going to need an extra
ounce of
um
trust display
and that's okay
this person who I'm going to love who I
want to date
um man got hurt bad
and I'm going to be so above board so
that she can breathe and she can lean
into this new relationship
I think you have to come to the place
where if you said hey
you're super secretive with your phone
and I I lived this for almost a decade a
guy who would never let me see the code
of his phone who would always hide his
phone and it ended up blowing up all
over me
I'm not comfortable being in another
romantic relationship where we have
secrets like that
and if he said well screw you if you
don't trust me I'm out of here I'm gonna
tell you Emily it's gonna hurt real bad
but you dodged another bullet
and if he laughs and says okay here you
go and it's a bunch of crude jokes
between him and some of the guys he
works with you can say you're gross
and move on about your day you see what
I'm saying
I do I do I bet I feel like oh man
this is easy for me to say I'm an old
married man right
but I want to tell you you're worth more
than hedging what you feel
I want to tell you Secrets will kill you
and can I tell you something kind of
hard ah I feel bad saying this but not
really
you're being secretive too
you're not telling him the truth either
yeah because the truth is you think
something's freaky going on let me tell
you one more thing about trauma it does
really finely tune your radar sometimes
and sometimes it can overtune it to
where you see trauma everywhere and
there's not actually dating somebody new
that's great
it also though can catch before you even
realize it oh that is cheating 100
cheating I feel it
and so I want to tell you part of
getting reconnected with yourself and it
sounds like such lofty floofy language I
get that
it's learning to trust your gut again
another way to learn to trust your gut
again is to have gut instincts and act
on them I feel in my bones there's
something on that phone that you're
hiding from me
can I see it do you love me enough you
trust me enough because if not we've
been together for a year we probably
need to have a different conversation
or if they go yeah of course here
there you go
and by the way if
um
somebody's cleaning
like someone's
folding your underwear and putting in a
drawer they should be able to see your
phone
if y'all are sharing
DNA and you make kids together y'all
should be able to share phones for God's
sakes
having this eternal private life that is
separate
um having private thoughts having
private journals all that's good I mean
that's you working through yourself
having this private Universe I can get
real dicey real real fast I know because
I've been there you can get dicey real
fast
so that's just what let me say this
Emily you're not crazy
you're not crazy I would probably if I
was you if you were my mom if you were
my sister
um I would tell you go spend some time
with a trauma counselor who's trained
because you got some healing you need to
do I think you need to be very honest
with yourself about the behaviors that
you are finding that are setting off all
of your body's alarms
in your current relationship reminding
you of the past and I don't think you
just wipe those away as well this
happened back then because it may be
happening right now again
that may be happening right now again
I'll send you a copy of my brand new
book building a non-anxious life I want
you to work through all those exercises
and begin to look at your life and say
no no here's the places where without
even thinking about it I was choosing an
anxious existence
I was doing this unintentionally I was
doing this unintentionally I was doing
this unintentionally and I've created a
life of chaos and I'm done with it
I'm done with it
hang on the line we'll get you hooked up
call anytime
you're not crazy
so sorry that somebody hurt you
you're worth so much more we'll be right
back
hey what's up Dr John deloney here check
it out my new book building a
non-anxious life is now available for
pre-order here's the great news anxiety
is not the enemy we've been led to
believe I know this because I've walked
alongside countless folks over the last
two decades and I've struggled with this
too if you create a life of
intentionally living out the six daily
choices I've outlined in this book
you're gonna be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you you're
going to learn the choices you can make
day by day to create a more peaceful
joyful less chronically stressed
non-anxious life plus when you pre-order
my book I want to give you something to
help you today that's why you'll
instantly get my newest talk smoke fire
and freedom that I gave to several
thousand folks a few months ago where I
break down the misunderstandings in
myths we believe about anxiety how to
reclaim your freedom and how to build a
non-anxious life so pre-order building a
non-interest life today for just 20
bucks at John deloney.com
all right we're back at the end of the
show and I've got an awesome follow-up
email here all right back on June 16th
of 2023 Isaac from Charleston wrote in
it was ended up being on the show wanted
to know could he come back from
resentment his original email said this
separated from my wife and three kids
we got here is a tornado of hurt and
betrayal want us to work things out try
as hard to be all in
um here we are several months later and
she wants to try a lot of betrayal a lot
of hurt a lot of pain
um I feel ultimately it can be worth it
but I don't know the path and I'm hurt
so bad from before I don't want to be
hurt again
so we had him on the show talked through
it and here is his reply email
and by the way we'll put a link in the
show notes to the previous the original
um show if you want to go back and check
it out
here's what he writes it's awesome good
afternoon Jenna and the rest of the Dr
John deloney show team
I just wanted to provide a little update
of where we are now since I called in
after some time and seeing some actions
I made the choice that my wife was
serious about wanting to heal herself in
our marriage
a few weeks after my talk with Dr John
we attended a five-day marriage therapy
intensive together not long after that
my wife attended an addiction intensive
in Nashville Tennessee and has been
regularly attending 12-step programs and
working with me in our healing journey
together
I truly believe she has seen the light
and is very empathetic towards my needs
as Dr John put it in the show
I've also reflected and put in some work
on where I have contributed to our
marital issues and am working on my own
healing as well as and to be a whole
individual so that our marriage can be
whole
dude this is awesome this is amazing
we're still working towards moving back
in together and the logistics of putting
our pieces back together in a new way
and all that fun jazz
ah dude so great Isaac
a real quick want to walk through what
this sounds like because a lot of people
hear the show and they think okay this
person can just go have this
conversation and that conversation it's
all better it's not how life works
after the show for a couple of weeks
Isaac stood on what I told him and then
he sat down with his wife
and then she agreed all right let's do
an intensive and then probably from that
intensive it came out you got to go to
rehab before anybody gets better and she
did
and that takes weeks that takes time and
then in the re in the Intensive and at
rehab
he learned he had some work he had to do
he was not he was not perfect either
he's not on the Marvel team either
and he is and even after all that work
they're still navigating just moving
back in together
so never forget healing takes time it's
hard a lot of grinding work
and healing is always
worth it you are worth it my friends
we'll see y'all soon
[Music]